[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition des matins du sénat
aujourd'hui nous vous proposons de
suivre l'audition des trois locataires
de bercy
bruno le maire gérald darmanin et
olivier du soft il était auditionné hier
par la commission des finances du sénat
une audition en vue de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances 2009 1 et vous
allez voir à l'équation du budget elle
est compliquée pour le gouvernement
cette année il faut à la fois répondre à
la crise des gilet jaune et au
ralentissement de la croissance mondiale
bruno le maire a parlé de décision qui
favorise l'investissement et la
consommation
à la croisée des chemins entre une
politique de l'offre et de la demande
vous allez le voir sur une infographie
on a retenu quelques chiffres clés dans
ce budget le gouvernement prévoit une
baisse de 9 milliards d'euros d'impôts
sur les ménages via une réduction de
l'impôt sur le revenu et la suite de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
il revoit son objectif de suppressions
de postes de fonctionnaires à la baisse
cet été l'objectif était encore à fixer
à 15000 a finalement vous le voyez un
style seulement dix mille 500
suppressions de postes sur le
quinquennat
enfin comment financer ces mesures il a
beaucoup été question hier de la
conjoncture économique qui est favorable
en matière de taux d'intérêt
ils permettent à l'état d'économiser
cinq milliards d'euros en 2020 vous
allez le voir cette audition le ton est
rapidement monté entre bruno le maire et
vincent eblé le président de la
commission sur l'épineuse question de la
suppression de l' isf allez direction la
salle de la commission des finances pour
cette audition préparer pour aujourd'hui
par alice bardot est louée molliet saab
est d'abord réponse si vous le permettez
monsieur le président votre
interpellation que je comprends que nous
avons eu des échanges en séance publique
soit de programmation des finances
publiques
effectivement le premier ministre a
tranché sur le fait que présenteront une
loi de programmation des finances
publiques au printemps prochain ce qui a
pesé dans la balance si j'ose dire c'est
l'incertitude sans cesse reportée du
bric sites dont l'incarnation dans les
finances publiques est assez peu
évidente d'abord peu évident aussi que
nous comprenions exactement ce que
souhaitent nos amis britanniques et les
imputations dans les comptes publics
on voit des chiffres très différents
selon les instituts ce lorsque pense
également le gouvernement d'un bric site
sans accord dans les conditions qui
semblent se dessiner encore ce matin la
presse britannique a levé d'autres
incertitudes et puis évidemment la
réforme des retraites vous fait le lien
avec le projet de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale le choix qui a été fait
par le gouvernement est de laisser
plusieurs mois de concertation à projet
de loi de retraites sera déposé
également au printemps sur la table du
conseil des ministres y aura des
répercussions extrêmement importantes
sur les comptes sociaux
chacun sait que les retraites c'est à la
fois 14 % de la richesse nationale 28 %
de la dépense publique et de manière
générale
évidemment sur notre programmation une
question de démographie très importante
certes le haut conseil des finances
publiques a évoqué et ils veulent ira
sans doute demain matin migaud le fait
qu'il ya décalage avec la programmation
quand nous avions voté en 2017 à ceci
près que en 2017 il y avait
effectivement une croissance économique
prévue à 1,7
aujourd'hui les plus entre 1,3 et 1,4 ça
fait évidemment des recettes en moi mais
le budget 2020 est conforme au programme
de stabilité que le parlement a connu
ces derniers mois et singulièrement jeu
parlant de le dire en termes politiques
il est aussi conforme aux conclusions du
grand débat que le président république
a évoqué est aussi audois muet ce cas
être présenté madame pénicaud et madame
busin et que le sénat bien voulu adopter
également sur les comptes publics et
notamment le projet de loi de finances
avant j'aurais retenir c'est une
question de forme mais cette question de
forme je crois est importante et montre
la cohérence du gouvernement le 3 % de
gel que nous continuer à garder dans le
projet de loi de finances et le si j'ose
dire le sens series ont encore le gel
puisque nous par faisons porter le gel
cette année je pense que ça fera plaisir
au rapporteur général sur des endroits
qui par nature auparavant ne pouvait pas
être gelée c'est à dire que nous
mettions toujours 3% de gel le gène sur
la preuve d'activité par exemple alors
que nous savons dès le début de l'année
que ces crédits seront consommés et les
commissaires des finances remarqueront
que cette année en plus de passer de 8 à
3 %
oui % c'était le gel du quinquennat
précédent 3% 7 gel que je présente
depuis l'année 2017 qui est soucieuse de
l'autorisation parlementaire je ferai
d'ailleurs remarquer qui a toujours pas
eu de décret d'avancé conformément à mon
engagement devant votre assemblée et son
que
croire respectueux des amendements et de
la sincérité à sion budgétaire cette
année le gel porte d'ailleurs que sur
des crédits qui sont effectivement je la
bhl est donc annulables et pas sur des
crédits nôtre on sait que parents s'ils
ne sont pas ce qui renforce encore la
sincérité du budget que je suis
l'occasion de vous présenter
nous continuons la suppression des
petites axes une quinzaine de petites
tailles nous sommes ouverts aux débats
parlementaires ont supprimé davantage
c'est un point très important pour la
modernisation de l'état pour la
simplification évidemment de nos comptes
le public et par ailleurs nous prenons
en compte comme d'autres un élément la
question notamment de l'amendement de
madame pérol à l'assemblée nationale
mais soutenu par le sénat d'avoir un
document budgétaire qu'on appelle le
jaune qui regroupe l'ensemble des
dépenses et la fiscalité écologique
c'est un point très important ce
document jusqu'à présent n'existait pas
et je crois que vous avez pu être
informés on vous a fait parvenir
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs des sénateurs les travaux du
gouvernement sur le green budget thing
c'est à dire la possibilité de présenter
un projet de budget de 2021 qui sera
bien sûr comptable mais qui comptera
également des dépenses et des recettes
négatives ou positives pour
l'environnement
on aura l'occasion d'en rediscuter les
grands chief de ses comptes publics sont
intéressants et se s'arrête à trois
éléments que je voudrais vous donner 20
30 et 40 20 milliards c'est le 1 % dans
au milliard depuis de 2019
la baisse du déficit public tout
confondu je rappelle d'ailleurs que
lorsque nous sommes arrivés en
responsabilité nous étions à 3 4% de
déficit disait la cour des comptes le
pressent de projets si dense preuve
représente 2,2 pour cent
et si on fait un zoom sur l'état le
déficit de l'état baissent également
contrairement à l'année dernière puisque
tu auras 113 milliards dans le plf 2010
9 qu'on arrivera à exécuter à 97
milliard c'est à dire que nous avons
fait 11 milliard de mieux dans
l'exécution budgétaire on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
monsieur le président pour l'exécution
même si évidemment il ya encore quelques
incertitudes rai 3 - qui nous reste mais
vous aurez constaté qu'il n'y a pas eu
de décrets davance on attendra donc le
plfr et nous sommes autour de 93
milliards des déficits de l'état
ce déficit baisse reste très important
et il reste très important parce que
c'est l'état qui à assumer l'intégralité
des baisses d'impôts et c'est un point
très important d'ailleurs on aura débat
sans doute vous l'avez évoqué avec le ps
s on parle de trou la sécurité à 5
milliard 5 milliard c'est le trou plfss
93 milliard c'est le trou état est dans
le trou et haï a évidemment beaucoup de
mesures de baisses d'impôts qui sont
propres à l'état et qui améliore par
ailleurs le sol de la sécurité sociale
qu'on nous avons plus de cotisation
parce qu'on a fait plus de baisses
d'impôts du côté de l'état évidemment
cela se ressent mais c'est donc 20
milliards de déficit tout a pu en moins
trente 30 milliards c'est la baisse
d'impôts cumulé depuis le début de ce
quinquennat et ce sera même 40 milliards
à la fin du quinquennat
27 milliards pour les ménages 13
milliards pour les entreprises avec des
baisses d'impôts très importantes
notamment la baisse d'impôt sur le
revenu
5 milliards d'euros qui grâce à la fois
la source aux soutenu par l'important
général s'appliquera dès le mois de
janvier prochain pour tous les
contribuables
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires la prime décidé lors des
lois mme us et la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation 3,7 milliards qui fera
naître
évidemment la réforme de la fiscalité
locale qui évoquera olivier dussopt pts
cette baisse d'impôt est sans précédent
dans l'histoire de la république
le dernier gouvernement qui a baissé les
impôts qu'ils avaient le titre de
champion de baisse des impôts c'était le
gouvernement de monsieur lionel jospin
25 milliards d'euros à comparer aux 40
du président macron avec une croissance
qui était plus importante mais c'est de
ce record est donc désormais des le plf
2020 battu 40 milliards de dépenses
évitées 20 30 40 40 milliards de
dépenses évitées c'est la baisse de la
dépense publique en pourcentage
notre richesse nationale pour la
première fois depuis 20 ans elle descend
et elle descend de 55 à 53 % 53 4% du
pib
je rappelle que la moyenne de la dépense
publique tout administrations publiques
confondues dans ce gouvernement est de 0
4 % d'évolution sous le nikon sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy s'était
1,3 pour cent avec les crises
économiques et plans de relance et sous
le quinquennat de monsieur hollande cédé
0,9 ce gouvernement en termes de
dépenses publiques fait deux fois mieux
que françois hollande est trois fois
mieux que quinquennat précédent sur les
priorités de dépenses budgétaires les
plafonds déjà été communiquées au coeur
de l'été mais j'y reviendrai très
rapidement d'abord une augmentation
écrit
de l'écologie 800 millions d'euros c'est
une notion très importante + 3 milliards
d'augmentation des crédits du ministère
de mme adam borne depuis le début du
quinquennat le régalien qui se prend la
part du lion pardon de le dire ainsi 1
27 milliard selon la loi de
programmation militaire qui concerne nos
armes et sa modernisation une
augmentation très importante du
ministère de l'intérieur qui s'intéresse
par ailleurs en dans les lois de
faire qu'on a déjà voté son t2
c'est-à-dire son personnel et la
formation de la justice qui évidemment
appliquer plus une augmentation très
importante pour l'éducation nationale et
la recherche écologie régalien recherche
éducation sont les trois grandes
augmentations des dépenses que nous
présentons ainsi que la prime d'activité
qui va augmenter de 4 milliards entre
2018 et 2022 ce qui n'a pas de faits
précédents les économies portent sur des
réformes tout a pu conséquente c'est le
cas de la réforme de l'assurance chômage
dont la presse s'est fait l'écho des
économies budgétaires importantes de la
loi audiovisuelle publique qui a
présenté les ministres de la culture et
de l'audiovisuel voilà quelques jours
je rappelle d'ailleurs que le montant
des crédits pour lever le public est de
4 milliards d'euros c'est à dire un
milliard de plus que le montant que
dispose de mise la culture pour les
crédits culture sont donc évidemment un
sujet très important
la réforme du logement qui continue à
produire les économies notamment dans le
rls et la mise en place de l'acompte
temporisation des apl la question des
niches fiscales
j'y reviendrai très peu puisque ce sera
à bonnot maire qui je crois va détailler
les 650 millions d'euros de niches qui
sont évoqués dans ce projet de loi de
finances mais également constater la
réussite économique du gouvernement est
la baisse continue du chômage qui
évidemment produit un certain nombre de
baisses de dépenses publiques
il fait que moi de gens touchent des
prestations mais aussi une augmentation
de cotisations est également 6 milliards
de taux d'intérêt de gagner constaté
depuis la loi de programmation des
finances publiques je parle évidemment
en comptabilité budgétaire puisque en
comptabilité nationale a éperonné
mission ces 11 milliards d'euros mais ne
présentons le budget en comptabilité
budgétaire
enfin je voudrais souligner l'importance
pour le gouvernement d'avoir mis en
place l'unification du recouvrement dans
le projet de la finance comme présentant
qu'une très grande réforme de
l'administration fiscale
que je le dois de porter qui fait suite
au rapport de monsieur gardette est
lui-même qui fait suite aux attentes du
groupe cap 22 mais également de la fin
d'un certain nombre de contentieux
fiscaux très importants dont certes une
partie de l'argent arrivera pour 2019 ce
sera le cas de la sphère google mais
d'autres arriveront évidemment en 2020
et le meilleur recouvrement du
prélèvement à la source 2 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires
on peut dire que le ministre des comptes
publics et son secrétaire d'état se sont
creusé la tête
au lieu de se creuser la dette en ayant
une amélioration oui je voulais voir si
monsieur karoutchi suivait en en
améliorant ses amarres souchon et en
améliorant évidemment le recouvrement et
le recouvrement de l'impôt
moi je voudrais enfin souligné avant de
passer la parole à olivier dussopt sur
la question de la fiscalité locale qui
va vous amener à quelques journées
quelques nuits de débats très
intéressants je n'imagine de se baigner
sur la question très important de la
lutte contre la fraude sur lequel le
sénat et singulièrement le ce président
sera portée en général votre commission
s'est penchée d'argent merci monsieur
d'allier d'avoir été présents notamment
l'une des restitutions qui je crois est
intéressante avec les professionnels de
la profession comme disait godard nous
mettons beaucoup de dispositions de
lutte contre la fraude
vous savez que la loi fraude que nous
avons travaillé ensemble d'ailleurs a
été validée intégralement par le conseil
constitutionnel encore avant-hier par
une qpc très intéressante qui valide la
fin du bureau de bercy suite à la
demande d'un d'une part dont des
personnes qui étaient concernés les
dispositifs de lutte contre la tva
notamment la tva plateforme continue le
travail très important qu'a fait le
sénat je préférerais que ce texte soit
en direct et j'en remercie la direction
de la législation fiscale dans le texte
non pas par ordonnance qui nous
permettra un débat technique mais très
intéressant et par ailleurs il ya
d'autres dispositions de lutte contre la
fraude une qui fait en ce moment
discussions qu'à l'article 57 du projet
loi de finances sur l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux
non pas pour les petits pardon dire
comme un fraudeur mais pour ceux qui
notamment ont du mal à avoir la vérité
de déclarations de revenus dans le pays
de résidence
cette indisposition qui a été mis en
place par la grande-bretagne déjà et qui
montre son efficacité est évidemment en
accord avec le conseil d'état et demain
avec le
les protections est évoquée par la cnil
nous avons également la proposition du
président de la répulique lors du grand
débat sur le paiement de l'impôt en
france par les dirigeants d'entreprises
qui ont des intérêts évidemment français
le président de la république l'avait
évoqué mais aussi un certain nombre de
dispositions de lutte contre la fraude
on aura l'occasion de discuter davantage
sur la liste des pays que nous mettrons
à jour et sur l'augmentation des crédits
du ministère de l'action des comptes
publics notamment informatique pour
améliorer la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale de datamining 65 millions
d'euros de plus pour payer cette dette
numérique que le cn a d'ailleurs demandé
et que la cour des comptes avait relevé
avec votre autorisation monsieur
présidence de la parole à monsieur du
soft merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général mais là mais si les
sénateurs deux points pour compléter le
propos de gérald darmanin un premier sur
le cadre des relations financières entre
l'état les collectivités et le second
sur la réforme de la fiscalité locale
depuis 2018 le choix a été fait de
cesser la baisse unilatérale des
dotations de l'état aux collectivités
dans leur enveloppe globale
nous avons tous en tête que 2018 a été
une année difficile d'un point de vue
pédagogique dans la mesure où
l'évolution des potentiels financiers du
fait des modifications de périmètre des
intercommunalités s'était traduit par
des jeux de montées ou descentes des
dotations des communes qui n'avaient
peut avoir qui n'avait que peu à voir
avec le montant global de la dgf
attribuée par l'état aux communes
nous restons sur cette logique de
stabilité et nous le faisons d'autant
plus que les collectivités le joue le
jeu
la maîtrise des dépenses publiques les
322 collectivités concernées par le
contrat dit de cahors affiche des
dépenses réelles de fonctionnement à
moins viril -0 2% et globalement toutes
collectivités confondues nous sommes
autour de +0 4% donc très en deçà de
l'objectif de modération de la hausse
des dépenses indirectes 2%
c'est la raison pour laquelle en 2020
nous proposons que la dgf soit stable à
26 9 milliards d'euros et que plus
globalement les concours de l'état aux
collectivités vont augmenter de 600
millions d'euros pour passer de kapo
passé à 48,9 milliards d'euros il faut
expliquer l'augmentation de 600 millions
d'euros
il s'agit
200 millions d'augmentation de l'
enveloppe normée et pour environ 500
millions d'une dynamique lié à la tva
d'une part la fraction de tva perçue par
les régions qui va augmenter de 128
millions d'euros entre 2019 et 2020 et
au total nous serons sur une
augmentation depuis 400 millions d'euros
entre le montant de dgf 2017 des régions
et la fraction de tva que l'état leur
alloue désormais en 2020 et le fctva
deuxième composante est aussi dynamique
puisque entre 2019 et 2020 du fait de la
reprise des investissements
nous sommes à plus de 350 millions de f
cet hiver et donc on arrive ainsi à plus
600 millions d'euros
des concours de l'état aux collectivités
locales il faut préciser que parmi ces
concours
nous avons fait trois choix le premier
joie et de maintenir le rythme de
progression de la péréquation
le smic reste gelé comme les années
précédentes mais nous continuons à
augmenter de 90 millions l'a déçu de 90
millions la dsr de 30 millions la
dotation de péréquation des
intercommunalités de 10 millions la
dotation de péréquation des départements
cela me permet de garder donc le même
niveau
nous avons fait le même choix en matière
d'investissement puisque le montant
total des subventions de l'état à
l'investissement des collectivités
restent autour de 9 milliards d'euros
dont 2 milliards consacrés au soutien au
bloc local par la detr et la ds il qui
restent sur des niveaux équivalents au
tour de deux milliards d'euros à l'année
précédente
troisième choix dans ce ce bloc des
concours financiers de l'état aux
collectivités
la volonté que nous affichons depuis
maintenant trois ans de diminuer les
variables d'ajustement
nous savons que les variables
d'ajustement elles sont des outils qui
transforme l'exercice budgétaire en
exercice et lisible et donc notre
objectif est de diminuer les variables
d'ajustement de diminuer les montants
engagés pour que les dotations ainsi
décider soit les plus lisible possible
pour les collectivités les variables
d'ajustement en 2020 s'élèveront à 120
millions d'euros contre 160 159 en 2010
9 293 en 2018 et 539 en 2017 ce qui nous
permet donc d'afficher une diminution
des variables d'ajustement presque 5 un
peu plus de 4 plus exactement depuis
2017 et donc de contribuer à la
lisibilité du budget
des dotations de l'état versée aux
collectivités locales avec ce cadre qui
je crois permet de poser un principe de
stabilité et de reconstruire la
confiance entre l'état les collectivités
pour ce qui concerne les concours de
l'état aux collectivités locales
nous ajoutons la réforme de la fiscalité
l'hôtel nous sommes sont des chiffres
importants puisqu'il s'agit pour l'état
sur la période totale de suppression la
taxe d'habitation de trouver 10 8
milliards d'euros une partie conséquente
de ses 18 milliards sont prévus dans la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques qui avait été adoptée fin 2017
et nous aurons l'occasion de documenter
la trajectoire d'économies nécessaires
lors de la prochaine loi de
programmation pour les 20% tout cas le
coût afférent à la suppression totale
nous supprimons totalement donc la taxe
d'habitation pour les résidences
principales
les 80% ménages qui font l'objet
aujourd'hui d'une exonération paieront
ces jours ci pour une dernière fois un
tiers la taxe d'habitation qu'ils paient
en 2017 et l'année prochaine une paire
orient et en 2010 en 2021
les 20% de ménages qui continuent à
payer la taxe d'habitation verront leur
taxe d'habitation baissé d'un tiers puis
d'un deuxième tiers en 2022 pour
finalement ne plus rien payer en 2023
cela représente une économie moyenne par
ménage de 723 euros
et donc ce sont 7 123 euros de pouvoir
d'achat que nous rendons aux français il
faut tenir l'engagement du président de
la république pris en novembre 2010 est
de donner aux collectivités est une
ressource en compensation qui soit à la
fois pérenne dynamique et juste au pica
juste dans le sens nécessaire pour
l'exercice de leurs missions
cela nous a amenés à proposer le schéma
suivant nous maintenons évidemment
sinoussi jeudi en supprimant sur les
taxes la taxe d'habitation sur les
stalles résidence principale nous
maintenons la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires
nous maintenons la possibilité pour les
collectivités locales de voter des
majorations pour les logements vacants
en particulier et nous nous concentrons
sur le seul aspect des résidences
principales
les intercommunalités verront leurs
recettes
leur perte de recettes compensée par
l'affectation d'une fraction de tva sur
le même modèle que les régions et donc
avec la même dynamique celle qu'on peut
constater aujourd'hui sur la fraction
tva dont bénéficient les régions
les régions qui sont intéressés à la
taxe d'habitation non pas parce qu'elle
en perçoivent mais parce qu'aujourd'hui
elles perçoivent environ 300 millions
d'euros de frais de gestion de taxe
d'habitation dans le cadre d'accords
financiers antérieures des ronces et 300
millions compensé par des dotations le
département qui va perdre sa taxe
foncière profit des communes sera
compensée par l'affectation d'une
fraction de tva fraction de tva calculé
sur la base du taux de 2019 et des
valeurs locatives 2020 c'est un élément
important et contrairement aux communes
pour lesquelles nous proposons que le
taux retenu sur le taux de 2010 est
telle que prévue par la loi de
programmation
nous considérons que les départements
lors du vote de la loi de programmation
ne pouvait imaginer en tout cas ce qu'il
imaginait il ne pouvait prévoir que
leurs taxes que la taxe foncière qu'ils
perçoivent leur seraient retirés donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
prenons les valeurs locatives 2020 et le
taux 2019 pour les communes
il s'agit donc d'affecter aux communes
la part de taxe foncière sur les
propriétés les propriétés bâties perdre
perçue par les départements nous
retenons donc comme référence de
compensation les valeurs locatives de
2020 et le taux de 2010 est tel que le
prévoit le projet de loi de finances qui
vous est soumis ainsi à partir de 2021
le nouveau modèle de financement des
collectivités s'appliquera intégralement
et les contribuables qui continueront à
payer la taxe d'habitation au titre des
20% de contribuables continueront
jusqu'en 2022 et 2023 pour ce qui
concerne l'état verront leur impôt
finalement la recette de leur impôt
nationalisées pour qu'il n'y ait pas
deux systèmes qui cohabitent mais une
bascule d'un système à l'autre
comment est-ce que nous allons procéder
pour garantir des compensations qu'ils
soient justes puisque évidemment la taxe
foncière perçue par un département sur
une commune n'est pas nécessairement
égal à la taxe d'habitation perçue par
la commune
certaines communes seront sous compenser
d'autres surcompensé il y à un peu moins
de 25 mille communes qui sont sur
compenser un peu plus de 10000 qui sont
sous compenser nous allons mettre en
place un coefficient correcteur et faire
en sorte que lorsqu'une commune perçoit
aujourd'hui 80 euros taxes d'habitation
et que le département père soit 100
euros taxes foncières on met un
coefficient correcteur à 0,8 ce qui
garantit la neutralité des transferts ce
qui est important a précisé relève de
plusieurs points d'abord le fait que
la compensation sera une compensation
dynamique dynamique parce que appuyé sur
l'évolution des valeurs locatives de la
taxe foncière et donc sa garantie cette
dynamique et pour les communes elles
oseront le pouvoir de taux sur la
totalité de la taxe foncière à
l'exception de la fraction que
perçoivent certaines intercommunalités
la deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
fait le choix de ne pas appliquer de
coefficients correcteurs aux communes
pour lesquelles la surcompensation
serait inférieure ou égale à dix mille
euros cela représente 2300 commune la
plupart le pardon ça représente 7300
commune pardonnez-moi 7000 d'entre elles
ont moins de 1000 habitants
et vous savez mieux que que nous combien
ça peut être important pour des communes
de petite taille de bénéficier d'une
recette fiscale même de quelques
milliers d'euros supplémentaires
il faut aussi préciser que le
coefficient correcteur s'applique aux
produits lors de la compensation mais
que si un maire fait usage de son
pouvoir de taux il bénéficiera de la
totalité de la recette ainsi produite
sans que le coefficient correcteur soit
appliquée à la recette en question nous
proposons enfin une clause de revoyure
tous les trois ans il ya manière à
pouvoir voir comment ce système
fonctionne ici la lieue de s'il ya lieu
de le faire évoluer
je précise pour terminer monsieur le
président que avec ce système qui
ressemble à une forme de prélèvement à
la source sur les recettes des communes
surcompensé au bénéfice des sous
compenser il ya en deux intérêts qui
sont peut-être technique mais important
le premier intérêt c'est que nous ne
reproduisons pas la mécanique du fndd
jirs qui se traduit par le fait de fixer
dans le temps des recettes aux dépenses
pour les collectivités sans tenir compte
de l'évolution de leurs conditions
économiques que l'on peut traduire aussi
par les valeurs locatives
la deuxième que l'ensemble des systèmes
de prélèvements pour les surcompensé de
reversement pour les sous qu'on pense et
transitera par le compte d' avance de
l'état avec les collectivités
ce qui signifie que l'intégralité des
recettes versées aux collectivités en la
matière y compris pour les sous qu'on
pense et auront une nature de recettes
fiscales ce qui est important puisque
vous savez qu'il est quand même plus
facile et le passé la montre est de
diminuer de manière unilatérale les
dotations aux collectivités plutôt que
de recettes fiscales
je précise enfin dernier point pour
finir sur un chiffre là le montant total
de la taxe d'habitation perçue par les
communes sur
résidence principale s'élève à 16
milliards d'euros
jeudi 16 milliards d'euros alors jusqu'à
présent nous parlions de 15 milliards
sans puisqu'en fait 15 milliards sans
c'était sur la base des valeurs
locatives de 2018 et que nous avons
actualisé nos chiffres le montant total
de la taxe son sirh perçue par les
départements s'élève à 15 milliards à 15
milliards cent et donc il y a un écart
de 900 millions d'euros
ces 900 millions d'euros seront traitées
de deux manières par le biais du compte
d' avance avec quelques centaines de
millions d'oeufs frais de gestion pour
garantir là aussi que l'intégralité des
recettes de systèmes soient de nature
fiscale
et puis par ailleurs la ville de paris
par son statut particulier est
applicable notamment depuis le 1er
janvier 2018 ne peut pas intégrer un
système qui consisterait à transférer la
taxe foncière du département vers la
commune puisque la connectivité exercent
les deux missions simultanément c'est la
raison pour laquelle la sous
compensation peut connaître et la ville
de paris sera compensée par une fraction
de tva sur le modèle des départements à
hauteur de un peu plus de 600 millions
d'euros avec la dynamique que l'on
connaît merci messieurs du soft monsieur
le ministre le maire qui nous a rejoints
merci monsieur le président pardon
d'abord pour mon retard quand la
ponctualité allemande est une légende et
des avions d'une berlin peuvent être
très très en retard nous avions aux deux
heures de retard donc je vous prie de
m'en excuser
je voudrais en complément des propos du
ministre des comptes publics et du
secrétaire d'état en charge des
collectivités locales notamment présenté
le contexte global dans lequel nous
avons fait avec ce budget 2020 un
certain nombre de choix politique
cohérent par rapport aux grands choix
que nous avions fait avec le premier
ministre et le président la république
depuis 2017
deux éléments de conjoncture et de donne
économique sur la conjoncture et tous
les éléments dont nous disposons depuis
plusieurs semaines ne font que le
confirmer
nous sommes on
comté à risque de ralentissement fort de
la croissance mondiale c'est dû
notamment aux tensions commerciales
entre la chine et les etats-unis qui
n'ont cessé de s'aggraver depuis
plusieurs mois c'est dû aux tensions
dans la région du golfe dont nous avons
vu encore récemment l'impact sur le prix
du baril de pétrole
et c'est dû aux tensions en europe avec
le risque de plus en plus fort d'avoir
un break site sans accord qui pourrait
évidemment affecté l'union européenne le
deuxième point plus structurelle
c'est cette nouvelle donne économique
que nous avons depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois qui conjugue
ralentissement économique et croissance
faible taux d'inflation faible en
dessous de la cible de la banque
centrale européenne et taux d'intérêt
faibles voire négatifs
cette nouvelle donne économique elle est
inconnue dans la zone euro et en europe
et donc elle amène aussi des réponses
nouvelles et des réflexions sur la
meilleure manière de réagir les choix
que nous avons faits sont de trois
ordres
d'abord contrairement à ce que j'entends
dire beaucoup ici ou là nous maintenons
une politique de l'offre et je ne
laisserai pas passer les critiques qui
laisse entendre que nous aurions
renoncer une politique de l'offre il y
aurait tournant à tous ceux qui disent
qu'il n'y a pas de politique de l'offre
je demande de regarder ce qui est fait
pour les entreprises
l'année prochaine un milliard d'euros de
baisses d'impôts supplémentaires la
poursuite de la baisse de l'impôt sur
les sociétés qui touchera toutes les
entreprises c'était une demande légitime
des entrepreneurs c'est à dire aussi
bien les entreprises de plus de 250
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
que les pme auront une baisse de los
reyes dès 2020 même si nous avons tenu à
distinguer des très grandes entreprises
qui auront une baisse de 33 3 à 31 des
entreprises plus modestes qui l auront
une baisse plus significative de 33,3 à
28%
mais la peau ces sociétés passera bien
pour toutes les entreprises c'est le
propre d'une politique de l'offre
nous allons confirmer la trajectoire de
baisse de liesse à 25% pour toutes les
entreprises sans exception en demie
2 c'est bien le propre c'est une
politique de l'offre nous avons refusé
des différentes propositions de
modification du crédit impôt recherche
parce que nous estimons que c'est ce qui
fait l'attractivité de la france et que
ce dispositif même s'il peut être
encadrés pour les frais de
fonctionnement sur le coeur des
dispositifs ne voulons pas y toucher
parce qu'il permet aux entreprises
d'investir d'innover et d'être
compétitive nous avons maintenu
l'intégralité des allégements de charges
et alors que certains économistes nous
disait vous pourriez faire des
allègements de charges en biseau parce
qu'ils sont moins efficaces à partir
d'un certain niveau de salaire
nous nous avons estimé que lancer le
message de revenir ces allègements de
charges
c'était de lancer un message négatif
pour les entrepreneurs lancer le message
que dans le fond la compétitivité-coût
c'est bon le contrat a été rempli et on
pouvait revenir sur cette compétitivité
coût c'est pas du tout notre analyse
nous nous estimons qu'il faut maintenir
l'intégralité des allègements de charges
pour les entreprises
ajoutez à ça tous les dispositifs qui
ont été mis dans pacte notamment sur les
seuils sociaux soit transmission
d'entreprise sur l'actionnariat salarié
et vous voyez que vous avez des éléments
clés d'une politique de l'offre qui sont
confirmés dans ce budget je regrette que
ce soit les analystes extérieur et
étrangers qui reconnaissent
l'attractivité de la france et pas
forcément les organisations patronales
nous estimons que nous faisons le
nécessaire pour améliorer l'attractivité
de la france et s'est reconnue par
l'ensemble des analystes étrangers
le deuxième choix politique que nous
faisons c'est celui du rétablissement de
nos finances publiques
enfin nous tenons compte bien entendu de
cette nouvelle donne économique dont je
vous ai parlé avec des taux d'intérêt
qui sont faibles voire négatifs et qui
gérald darmanin romain certainement
parler ou un impact positif sur la
charge de la dette qui se chiffrent à
plusieurs milliards d'euros
je vais très clair sur un point il n'est
pas question pour nous de laisser filer
d'endettement public
il a filé au cours des dix dernières
années + 30 points il est passé de 64 %
à 98 % c'est la situation que nous avons
trouvé plus 30 points en dix ans
certains avec une crise bien entendu on
ya répondu par plus de dépenses
publiques plus d'investissements et donc
plus de dette
notre analyse maintenant c'est qu'il ne
serait pas raisonnable de laisser filer
d'endettement public et donc tout le
stabilisons à la baisse je reconnais
bien volontiers que nous avons ralenti
le rythme pour tenir compte de ces taux
d'intérêt qui sont négatifs quand je dis
stabilisait à la baisse que si je vous
dis qu'il baisse comme c'est juste d'un
point vous me direz que c'est peu
significatif mais la direction est la
bonne
et en tout état de cause je pense qu'il
ne serait pas raisonnable de laisser
filer cet endettement est de courir le
risque le jour les taux d'intérêt
remonteront de laisser une charge la
dette qui exploserait aux générations
suivantes
ce point de vue là vous me permettrait
de considérer que les taux d'intérêts
négatifs ont évidemment des avantages
pour les finances publiques
ils ont évidemment des avantages pour
tous les ménages français quand la
capacité d'emprunter pour s'acheter un
bien immobilier
mais ils ont aussi beaucoup de
désavantages et ils peuvent représenter
à terme un risque
il joint des avantages d'abord pour tous
les ménages modestes qui ne peuvent pas
emprunter et qui du coup voit les
revenus de leurs comptes diminué il on a
des avantages également pour un certain
nombre de secteurs notamment le secteur
financier bancaire ou assurance qui
perdent en profitabilité et qui
représente je le rappelle huit cent
mille emplois dans notre pays
de ce point de vue là je ne pense pas
que les taux d'intérêt bas ou négatifs
puisse constituer l'armature d'une
politique économique
le troisième choix que nous faisons
après celui du rétablissement de nos
finances publiques dont je veux pour
preuve le niveau de dépenses publiques
de déficits publics à 2,2 en 2020 c'est
le niveau le plus faible depuis
quasiment une vingtaine d'années skil
troisième choix que nous faisons c'est
celui du soutien au travail c'est le fil
rouge notre politique économique depuis
plus de
deux ans maintenant nous voulons que le
travail paye et quand vous regardez la
réalité de la situation économique de
notre pays depuis 2008 depuis la fameuse
crise financière qui a été mentionné
tout à l'heure ce qui est frappant c'est
que les ménages les plus modestes ceux
qui ont les salaires les plus faibles
sont ceux qui ont mis le plus de temps à
se remettre de cette crise financière et
économique et qui aujourd'hui encore
n'ont pas rattrapé totalement le niveau
de vie qui pouvait être le leur au
moment de la crise financière
et s'il ya eu sept explosions des gilet
jaune
ce n'est pas parce que tout d'un coup
des revendications illégitime se
seraient manifestés
c'est parce que depuis plus de dix ans
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes se
sont aperçu qu'avec leurs revenus leur
travail ils ne pouvaient pas vivre
dignement et que cet effet-là a été
masqué par une politique de
redistribution puissante en france qui
réduit évidemment les inégalités mais si
on retire cette politique de
redistribution et qu'on regarde les
inégalités à la base inégalités brut
s'aperçoit qu'effectivement le niveau
des salaires pour les plus modestes ne
leur permet pas de vivre dignement de
leur travail et corriger ça c'est ce qui
est plus difficile ce que vous avez le
choix entre donner des coups de pouce
successifs au smic et courir le risque
de mettre les moins qualifiés au chômage
donc ce n'est pas la bonne politique
ne rien faire c'est pas la bonne
politique non plus parce que vous
laissez ce qu'au niveau de salaires les
plus faibles dans une situation qui est
intenable pour leur vie quotidienne et
pour leurs familles ou faire ce que nous
faisons depuis plus de deux ans
c'est-à-dire complété par des
dispositifs qui sont la prime d'activité
les heures sup défiscalisées
la baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu qui
va bénéficier principalement à la
première tranche de l'impôt sur le
revenu ou la mise en place de
dispositifs d'intéressement sans aucune
taxe suppression la taxe à 20 % soit
intéressement pour que tous ceux qui ont
un salaire modeste puisse avoir à la fin
du mois un niveau de revenu net qu'ils
soient plus élevés
et je pense que cette politique est les
clés quelles que soient nos convictions
politiques
je pense que quand on regarde
sereinement et lucidement la situation
économique de notre pays
permettre à ceux qui travaillent et qui
ont les niveaux de salaires les plus
faibles de rattraper le choc profond
qu'ils ont connue avec la crise
financière et économique 2008 2008
c'est juste et c'est nécessaire mieux
rémunérer le travail c'est de ce point
de vue là pour nous un objectif
absolument stratégique est à la fois un
objectif économique de cohésion sociale
et de justice
enfin ces trois choix nationaux la
politique de l'offre le rétablissement
des finances publiques et la meilleure
rémunération du travail
il s'accompagne aussi d'un choix
européen quand je vous dis qu'il ne
s'agit pas pour la france de s'endetter
plus je constate malgré tout qu'il y à
d'autres membres de la zone euro qui eux
ont un niveau d'endettement un niveau de
déficit public qui leur donnent des
marges de manoeuvre budgétaires qui
doivent utiliser maintenant et j'ai pu
rappeler nouvelle fois à berlin mon
homologue allemand monsieur jones comme
je le fais depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines qu'il était temps que
l'allemagne investissent davantage
l'allemagne a commencé à le faire mais
je suis convaincu qu'elle peut faire
davantage investir plus dans
l'innovation dans la recherche pas
uniquement dans les infrastructures ou
dans le bâtiment pour relancer la
croissance non seulement en allemagne
mais aussi la zone euro c'est la
condition du retour de la prospérité
dans la zone euro et en france merci
messieurs les ministres de vaud exposé
liminaire qui sont extrêmement éclairant
nous allons passer maintenant à une
batterie de questions et vous me
permettrez d'ouvrir en quelque sorte le
processus de questionnements en évoquant
devant vous le travail parlementaire car
évidemment le gouvernement dans sa
responsabilité exécutive procède sur ces
questions un travail permanent
nous nous efforçons au sein de notre
commission des finances de produire
également un certain nombre de travaux
d'analysé et de réflexion et en
particulier comme vous le savez sans
doute nous menons avec le rapporteur
général
une évaluation de la transformation de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune en
impôts sur la fortune immobilière et la
création d'un prélèvement forfaitaire
unique
nous remettrons nos conclusions devant
la commission des finances le 9 octobre
prochain
donc dans un délai désormais extrêmement
court à cet égard nous vous avons
adressé un questionnaire à vous monsieur
le ministre le maire le 23 avril dernier
puis une relance en juillet sur 29
réponses manquantes sur 54 plus de la
moitié excusez du peu
malgré cette relance du mois de juillet
et de très nombreux contacts y compris
des appels personnels avec vos équipes
j'ai moi même appelez votre directeur de
cabinet adjoint
il y a déjà au moins une dizaine de
jours nous n'avons toujours pas eu de
réponse de votre part sur des données
dont certaines sont pourtant purement
factuel comme le rendement effectivement
constatés de la hausse des prélèvements
sociaux sur les revenus soumis au père
fut alors me dit qu'il y aurait un mail
aujourd'hui je ne prends pas que ce soit
le simple hasard du calendrier
lorsque le fait de vous recevoir a
peut-être aidé les choses ce midi nous
avons découvert avec stupéfaction je
dois le dire que le comité d'évaluation
placée sous l'égide de francs stratégie
et qui travaillent sur le même sujet a
pu bénéficier de certaines informations
que nous vous demandons depuis près de
six mois
la dg fuit pas par exemple rédiger pour
ce comité
une contribution entière sur l'évolution
des départs à l'étranger des redevables
de l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
alors que nous vous avons sans succès
demandé un simple tableau de chiffres
sur ce même sur ce même sujet que nous
n'avons jamais pu obtenir le
gouvernement entend t-il c'est ma
question réellement fournir aux
parlementaires les informations dont ils
ont besoin pour travailler également où
sommes-nous là comme une chambre
d'enregistrement d'attendre que les
dispositions proviennent du gouvernement
quand elles sont prêtes et de les
valider par un vote
nous avons nous j'irai la mission
constitutionnelle de faire aussi notre
travail vous semble-t-il normal que la
représentation nationale soit moins bien
traités que les experts de tel ou tel
comité d'évaluation tout cela relève
d'une juste application des dispositions
de la loi organique sur les lois de
finances tout simplement
c'était ma première question
la seconde nous observons que le
gouvernement communique très largement
sur le fait que le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages va augmenter l'an prochain de 9
milliards d'euros grâce aux nouvelles
baisse des prélèvements obligatoires
s'agit toutefois d'une présentation
légèrement trompeuses ou pour le moins
tronquée puisque ces baisses de
prélèvements s'accompagnent souvent en
parallèle de diminutions de prestations
sociales
le gouvernement propose d'ailleurs une
nouvelle fois dessous revaloriser les
prestations sociales à l'article 67 du
plf en limitant à 0,3 pour cent la
progression des aides personnelles au
logement et l'allocation aux adultes
handicapés véritable politique du rabot
qui amène à diminuer les prestations en
termes réels pour des personnes qui ne
bénéficieront pas de la réforme du
barème de l'impôt sur le revenu cette
mesure amputerait le pouvoir d'achat des
plus modestes
est ce vraiment en réduisant les revenus
réels de ces personnes que l'état doit
aller chercher les ressources qui lui
manque
troisième et en ce qui me concerne
dernière question la cnil vient de
rendre hier un avis très sévère sur un
article du projet de loi de finances
pour 2020 permettant à titre
expérimental la collecte de données à
caractère personnel publiées sur
internet par les utilisateurs de plates
formes en ligne
elle rappelle qu'une telle
expérimentation dont il revient au
législateur
évidemment d'apprécier l'opportunité
doit s'accompagner de garanties fortes
afin de préserver les droits et libertés
des personnes concernées quelle réaction
avez vous face à cette mise en garde
messieurs les ministres oui si vous
voulez sur la première question monsieur
le président ait pas de malentendus
entre votre commission et les ministères
de l'économie et des finances nous
fournissons aux parlementaires
évidemment toutes les informations
qu'ils demandent je voudrais juste
préciser deux choses d'abord il ya un
comité d'évaluation et moi je regrette
que pour des raisons juridiques que je
trouve obscures le sénat ne puisse pas
être associée directement au comité
d'évaluation qu'elle fait un travail
tout à fait remarquable en totale
transparence sur nos choix en terme de
fiscalité du capital
il y à une députée nadia et qui est dans
ce comité d'évaluation alors je crois
que pour des raisons juridiques il faut
encore qui m'échappe totalement le sénat
ne pouvait pas être dans ce comité
d'évaluation juridique ces politiques
nous l'avons formellement président
remettrait de déploré me représenter à
raison de un parlementaire pour la
chambre haute
un parlementaire pour la chambre basse
ne permet pas d'assurer la diversité de
notre représentation politique et nous
n'avons pas vocation en tant que
parlementaire alors que nous participons
à la décision d'intégrer des comités
d'experts
excusez-moi de vous interrompre nous ne
sommes pas des experts nous sommes des
acteurs de la vie politique sur ce que
nous ne plaçons au mieux des experts les
experts voulait qu'on veut qu'on ils
viennent ici ils nous rapportent leurs
travaux ils nous rendre leurs
conclusions et nous les analysons mais
nous ne sommes pas des experts
nous sommes des parlementaires vous
parlez à la représentation nationale ne
paie pas d excès r j'ai parfaitement
conscience de palets la représentation
nationale je regrette
cette position je regrette que c'est
d'un n'ai pas accepté de participer à un
comité d'évaluation auquel l'assemblée
nationale acceptait de participer et me
semble que dans le cadre de la réduction
de la dépense publique et de
l'efficacité de notre travail conjoint
avoir un comité d'évaluation dans lequel
se retrouvent des parlementaires et se
retrouve des experts il n'y a pas de
mépris avoir visité la terre
c'est ce qui permet d'avoir un travail
qui soit très sérieux dont je regrette
notre position vous critiquer la
position du gouvernement je me permette
de regretter que le sénat n'est pas
acceptée participants committee savez je
suis à ne pas nous transmet vraiment que
nous vous adressons par questionnaire
mais je vais y venir monsieur le
président je pense que depuis avril ce
n'est pas la peine de hausser le ton
j'estime que nous avons dans réveil
fermeté ce qui constituait ma conviction
et bien je l'écris le cam était ma
conviction je pense qu'il aurait été bon
que ses droits soient représentés dans
ce comité d'évaluation qui a fait avec
l'assemblée nationale un très bon
travail et qu'il n'est jamais bon de se
mettre à côté d'un travail sérieux fait
leur un autre sans vous le verrez dès le
9 octobre et qu'il n'y a aucun mépris
avoir vis-à-vis des experts qui
participent à ce comité d'évaluation
call girls et cela serait d'ailleurs on
les a longuement écouté vous faites part
de votre conviction je vous fais part de
la mienne je regrette la position du
sénat là dessus
s'agissant de la transmission
d'informations nous allons vous fournir
toutes les informations nécessaires et
vaste choix que le gouvernement fournit
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat et à
la représentation nationale dans son
ensemble toutes les informations dont
elles ont besoin
nous vous apporterons les réponses en
temps utile le plus rapidement sera
évidemment le mieux ne mésestimez pas
non plus la charge de travail qui est
celle du ministère au moment où il
prépare le budget projet de loi de
finances pour 2020 et je redis à quel
point une évaluation faite conjointement
entre experts et représentants nationaux
me semble efficace
monsieur leur maman mais merci monsieur
le président vous ai posé de questions
j'ai commencé par là par la dernière sur
la cnil c'est une disposition qu'on
avait déjà évoqué lors du plf 2010 9
chacun s'en souvient et notamment dans
la loi frotteront c'était von est
présente et qui n'est pas nouvelle et
qui est aujourd'hui utilisée par de
grandes démocratie respectueuse des
libertés individuelles notamment la
grande bretagne
il s'agit non pas pour les petits
fraudeurs je le répète mais pour les
fraudeurs les plus importants ceux qui
utilisent le fait d'avoir une
possibilité de résidence à l'étranger de
déclarer ses revenus à l'étranger parce
qu'ils y passent notamment plus de six
mois plutôt que de payer ses impôts en
france et parmi les critères qui n'est
pas maître de lutter efficacement contre
cette fraude importante est que nos
compatriotes se comprennent peu il ya
notamment l'utilisation c'était le cas
pour des grands artistes des grands
sportifs ou des grands dirigeants de
fonds par exemple dans les pays que j'ai
nommé de pouvoir utiliser comme éléments
parmi d autres
les réseaux sociaux et singulièrement
des réseaux sociaux qui permettent la
géolocalisation
puisque les gens effectivement les
utilisent
nous avons soumis à la cnil
voilà six mois la disposition
législative qui ont retrouvé dans
l'article 57 me ce président de ce
projet de loi de finances la cnil a
rendu un premier avis et nous a dit que
cela relevait du domaine de la loi et
que nous devions le présenter en domaine
législatif nous avons retiré notre avis
la cnil puisque nous sommes partis du
couvert le conseil d'état et le conseil
d'état nous a répondu je tire la
disposition les éléments de la cnidh et
du conseil d'état nous a répondu que
c'était très intéressant mais que ça
relevait du pouvoir réglementaire et ça
devait pas avoir dans la loi et le
ministre des comptes publics avait alors
trois solutions soit ne rien faire ce
qu'il ne fera pas soit relever
uniquement du pouvoir réglementaire
alors que la cnil évoqué le fait que
c'est une évidemment une question de
liberté individuelle qui se pose est que
seuls les parlementaires pouvaient
l'adoubé la modifier ou la supprimer
s'il le souhaitait ou alors dire au
conseil d'état bah oui c'est pas la
première fois que quand il ya doute les
législateurs vont s'exprimer sur une
mesure qui relève du réglementaire est
obligé préféré qu'on mette qu'on ait un
débat
nous l'avons devant vous connaît un
débat au sénat et à l'assemblée sur
l'article 57 si le parlement souhaite
garder sa disposition ce que je souhaite
personnellement évidemment ça passera
par les fourches caudines du conseil
constitutionnel je rappelle conseil
d'état ne s'est pas opposé à cette
disposition est pourtant très
observatrice ce observateurs pardon des
questions de libertés publiques et le
plus raciste une qpc où il y aura sans
doute une censure du conseil
constitutionnel si les choses s'avérait
contraire aux libertés fondamentales et
les arrêter que je devrais prendre en
tant que mise et comptes publics suite à
l'adoption de l'article 57 du projet de
loi de finances que l'utilisation
effectivement de ces éléments en termes
d'intelligence artificielle de timing
seront évidemment soumis à la cnil et en
tant que ministre je répondrais
évidemment aux interrogations de la cnil
et jeffrey valider ces arrêtés par
l'acte il je pense cependant qu'il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut et jeudi notamment
dans une commission qui a beaucoup
travaillé
contre la fraude et le tout en
respectant les libertés individuelles il
faut comme laisser à mon avis aux
contrôleurs fiscaux et au fisc français
les moyens de lutter contre une fraude
organisée importante et qui utilise des
dispositions de résidence fiscale
différentes
il s'agit pas là de quelques centaines
d'euros mais de quelques millions
d'euros on pourra en discuter
évidemment si vous souhaitez plus en
amont en commission comme dans
l'hémicycle sur votre premier point vous
ne vous faites un procès rapide monsieur
le président et pardon de le dire qui
n'est pas conforme à la réalité des
faits les prestations sociales
aucune d'entre elles ne sont abaissés
elles ont même tendance à largement
augmenté pour une très grande partie
d'entre elles
c'est notamment le cas de celles qui
sont liées avec le travail je rappelle
qu'il est une augmentation de 4
milliards d'euros entre 2018 et 2022 de
la prime d'activité la prime d'activité
va pas c'est grosso modo trois milliards
et demi a quasiment 9 milliards dans le
quinquennat il n'y a pas je crois de de
comparaison possible avec les années
précédentes
je voudrais vous rappeler et dans là
franchement je ne comprends pas très
bien votre démonstration que
l'allocation adulte handicapé connaît sa
plus grande augmentation depuis sa
création et notamment une des paliers
qui sont très importants puisque c'est
avec 2 milliards d'augmentation monsieur
le président depuis 2010 est alors soit
on accepte ça on se dit qu'il faut
valoriser sur l'inflation soit on fait
des ressorts de 30 40 euros comme nous
le faisons et puis par ailleurs je vous
rappelle que le minimum vieillesse
connaît sa plus grande augmentation sous
n'importe quel cas qena est donc je
pense qu'on ne peut pas dire ce que vous
avez dit par ailleurs sur la
contemporanea sion des appels
je rappelle qu'il s'agit pas d'une
réforme de baisse du montant des appels
individuels
il s'agit de faire coïncider je pense
que chaque personne soucieuse à justice
sociale est très attaché notamment grâce
à la fois la source de faire coïncider
le moment où versé appel à quelqu'un
lorsqu'il en a besoin pas pour moment où
il n'a plus le droit
aujourd'hui la situation et pour ceux
qui ont touché les appels récemment soit
pour eux sauf les enfants le savent
c'est con mais plusieurs mois quand on
est dans le besoin pour toucher les
appelle alors qu'on en a besoin et ce
qu'il fait d'ailleurs que les gens
s'endettent ou que les gens font des
petits boulots quand ils sont étudiants
alors qu'ils devraient toucher la
solidarité nationale et non n'appliquent
pas la loi de la république et que
plusieurs mois après
avoir plus besoin de ces appels
notamment présents seront au travail et
que l'on retravaille décidément et qu'on
touche à salaires on continue à toucher
pendant un an un an et demi ces appels
et qu'évidemment on ne les rattrape
jamais quand il ya une période comme
aujourd'hui il on s'en réjouit où il ya
moins de gens qui sont éligibles aux apl
non pas parce qu'on a changé les règles
c'est parce que il ya une reprise
économique
évidemment il ya des économies de
constatations et la contemporanéité
ation des appels fait que si demain il y
aura sans doute un jour évidemment un
retournement de croissance économique
il ya plus de gens qui sont
bénéficiaires des appels il y aura une
dépense automatique plus importante
puisque les gens qui auront à demander
ces appels les toucheront dans le mois
qui suivra et non pas dans l'année qui
suivra donc je crois que sur votre
première remarque elles n'étaient pas
fondées sur la politique gouvernementale
s'il ya les économies et de son frère
dans les champs de transformation que
j'ai pu évoquer tout à l'heure merci
monsieur le ministre
le rapporteur général albi la demande
qualifiée merci messieurs les ministres
tout d'abord peut-être pour commencer
par la question de la fraude comme sur
la tasse gafa vous avez trouvé le sénat
qui a les deux commissions mixtes
paritaires de textes voltex gafsa ont
abouti et vous avez notamment récemment
pris tous connaissance de l'accord
concernant google savait que ces issues
ça repose directement sur deux
amendements qui avait été voté par le
sénat et qui n'étaient pas dans le texte
de l'assemblée nationale que nous avions
imposé en commission mixte paritaire
réussi à obtenir commission mixte
paritaire qui était d'une part la
possibilité de transiger
alors même qu'il y avait un contentieux
fiscal et le c'était par ailleurs la
convention judiciaire datée république
nous placer sur ce texte monsieur
ministre sur la fraude vous nous
trouverez notamment sur la fraude sur
la tva sur l'internet sujets que nous
avons soulevés depuis maintenant plus
d'une dizaine d'années avec philippe
dallier on est heureux enfin que ça
puisse intervenir dans ce texte
donc voilà le sénat son torse et souvent
d'avoir raison trop tôt alors la
première question
elle porte à peu sur la conjoncture donc
concrètement on a une baisse des taux
d'intérêt historique c'est vrai on peut
emprunter des taux ça permet sans doute
de repousser un petit peu le
redressement des comptes publics et
je me réfère à un horizon pas si
lointain que 2000 l'automne 2017
parce que nous avions cet automne 2010
est une loi de programmation on nous
disait que le seul public allait
s'améliorer que la dette elle est
vraiment baissé contrairement à ses
engagements on voit que le seul public
structurel là je parle du structurel du
5 milliards guerre et quant à la dette
française
l approche des 100 % du pib donc alors
la question ce que bruno le maire
normalement le ministre rassure plutôt
quand ils arrivent là il m'a plutôt
inquiété parce qu'il a rappelé
l'ensemble des facteurs qui pourraient
mauvaise nouvelle qui pourra intervenir
les chocs les crises commercial lé
risque pétroliers les problèmes qui
peuvent intervenir avec le break site
etc etc
le climat économique qui s'est ralenti
la question que tout le monde se pose en
cas de nouvelle crise en cas de
nouvelles choses de nouveaux chocs
quelles seraient les marges de manoeuvre
de la france l'arme monétaire je ne peux
pas aller plus loin
les hélicoptères ont distribué beaucoup
de deux caches sur l'europe et on aurait
évidemment aucune marche budgétaires
contrairement aux autres pays
donc voilà concrètement est ce que le
risque n'est pas que la cigale française
qui après avoir dépensé tout le
quinquennat ne serait elle pas dépourvu
en fin de quinquennat et
particulièrement en cas de retournement
de crise la deuxième question concerne
la perception par nos voisins à bruno le
maire vous dit qu'il revient d'allemagne
l'instant voilà l'allemagne c'est
intéressant il y à peu plus de 10 ans
nous étions au même niveau quasiment
d'endettement que l'allemagne en 2007
nous étions à 60 % d'endettement
aujourd'hui l'allemagne redescendu en
tuent 60% dans le seuil de maastricht ya
théoriquement nous approchons des 100 %
nos cas là ça va représenter d'après les
prévisions du fmi 45 points 45 points
d'écart d'endettement en 2022 entre la
france et l'allemagne
alors vous plaisir est-ce que c'est
grave pas grave il ya un élément très
tangible c'est que nous allons nous
paierons des intérêts beaucoup plus que
les allemands 22 milliards d'après les
prévisions du fmi en fin de quinquennat
voilà alors qu'elle est comment
expliquer que nous soyons finalement un
peu à contre courant de l'ensemble des
pays d'europe qui notamment le pays
d'europe du sud je pense à portugal à
l'espagne à la grèce qui auront réussi à
ce désordre
et pourquoi sa part est une spécificité
française qui justifie que nous soyons
le pays qui continuent à s'endetter là
où les autres se sont désendettés alors
évidemment il y avait un des éléments de
la maîtrise des dépenses publiques qui
était annoncé le chiffre nous le
connaissons tous par heure cinquante
mille emplois pour l'état c'est en 2000
emplois pour l'état moi je suis pas
fétichiste du chiffre je considère que
le service public
la meilleure manière dont on aurait pu
être plus important que le chiffre en
soi mais quand on regarde budget 2020
augmentation du nombre d'emplois pour
l'état les étapes et +122 +122 plus en
mode d'emploi est un vrai sens de l'état
et concrètement la diminution des et
épais au total sera 47 47 emplois en
moins en 2020
voilà donc l or est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement l'effort va reposer sur les
seules collectivités locales est-ce que
c'est elle qui vont devait refaire les
l'effort en matière de d'emplois publics
voilà les trois questions parce que je
pense que nombre de collègues auront
envie de répondre également sur la
question qui sera posée sans doute à
lisier du soap vous messieurs les
ministres notamment sur la taxe
d'habitation ou c'est un article 5 je
pense nous occupera quelques heures et
quelques sans doute quelques soirées
merci
m merci monsieur le président monsieur
avantage injuste pour les emplois donc
le présent la république s'était engagé
dans sa campagne à 50 mille suppressions
de postes et par ailleurs des créations
d'emplois notamment police gendarmerie
armée justice
nous n'attendons n'obtiendront pas les
50000 on fera 27000 c'est ce qui est le
chiffre que j'ai données soient ses 27
milles il y en a dix mille cinq cents
qu'ils ont fait dans ma propre
administration mais il ya d'autres
efforts qui sont faits je vois musée
économie et des finances etc à des
opérateurs du miss à la transition
écologique c'est le cas aussi le mystère
de la santé mais en dehors des médecins
et les infirmières bien sûr je prends un
exemple évident pour ce qui est
notamment du mts mis ses intentions
écologiques lorsque la météo france on
prend un supercalculateur vous y mettez
les moyens budgétaires c'est ce que nous
vous proposons dans le plf
évidemment il ya des nouvelles façons de
travailler qui demandent moins d'emplois
notamment dans l'opérateur météo france
donc 27000 c'est le nombre d'emplois que
nous allons créer nao supprimer pardon
pendant ce mandat et à 17000 si on
emplois créés donc il ya une différence
de 10500 ce sera pour les 10500 sur le
quinquennat effectivement plus en moins
cette année c'est le chiffre que vous
avez évoquées c'est un changement par
rapport à la non ce qui avait été fait
au début du quinquennat qui est conforme
je crois aussi à la demande du président
de la république d'écouter ce qui s'est
passé lors du grand débat
il me semble c'est mon avis personnel
puisque je parle que les mystères de
l'actionner comptes publics fait que
olivier du soft que lorsqu'elle est
transformations qui ont été faites on
peut économiser un certain nombre
d'emplois c'est à dire le cas du
prélèvement à la source
c'est le cas aussi par an de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
après c'est pas toujours évident de
supprimer un emploi je regardais pas les
parlementaires de la salle et on va voir
si dans le débat parlementaire les mêmes
qui souhaite que le 10 millions
d'emplois sont pas les mêmes qui
m'écrivent pour la réforme de la dgesip
non mais supprimer les agences de l'eau
je voudrais aussi vous parler simplement
de mon élection générale des finances
publiques c'est évidemment un sujet qui
est un sujet d'exécution qui s'étale sur
plusieurs années et budgétaire mais
seulement des mesures importantes
général sur la conjoncture s'agit pas
d'être pessimiste ou optimiste mais
lucide et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
éléments nouveaux
au moins trois qu'il faut avoir présent
à l'esprit et qui font que le
ralentissement que nous connaissons de
la croissance mondiale risque de se
poursuivre dans les mois qui viennent le
premier je le redis c'est cette crise
commerciale ouverte entre la chine les
etats unis dont je rappelle depuis deux
ans qu'elle ne fera que des perdants
pour donner une évaluation de ce que
cela représente
il y avait en début d'année 50 milliards
d'euros de biens chinois importés aux
états unis qui étaient taxés aujourd'hui
nous serons à la fin de l'année à 520
milliards d'euros d'importations
chinoises qui sont victimes de tarifs
américains à 10 ou à 25%
donc l'impact sur la circulation de ces
biens et du commerce mondial il est
évidemment considérable par ailleurs je
ne vois pas une administration
américaine dans de très bonnes
dispositions sur ces sanctions y compris
dans le cadre du conflit boeing airbus
vous savez qu'il ya un jugement l'om
sait qui a donné raison à boeing en
première instance qui permet aux états
unis d'infliger des sanctions à l'europe
nous devrions avoir la même possibilité
d'ici huit mois et ça fait plusieurs
mois que nous expliquons aux états unis
plutôt que d'avoir des sanctions
américaines sur la base d'une décision
de l'om c'est en octobre puis des
sanctions européennes en réaction aux
sanctions américaines vers le mois de
juin 2020 sur la base des mêmes
décisions de l'om c'est essayons de
trouver un accord à l'amiable
nous avons plaidé à tous les niveaux de
l'état pour un accord à l'amiable avec
les états unis il ya fort à parier que
malgré cela les états unis s'engageront
dans une politique de sanctions
ce serait une erreur économique je pense
que ce serait aussi une erreur politique
elle nous amènerait nécessairement à
réagir mais cela ne va évidemment pas
arrangé le niveau de la croissance
mondiale ni la croissance dans la zone
euro
nous plaidons pour un accord à l'amiable
mais il ya fort à parier que la décision
américaine sera différente
le deuxième élément c'est que vous avez
en conséquence de cela une croissance
allemande qui a fortement fléchi
parce que l'industrie automobile
allemande est la première
victime de ce ralentissement du commerce
mondial le troisième élément je les cite
et c'est le break site que nous
évoluions environ 0,2 point de pib comme
impact sur la zone euro d'ici l'année
prochaine la seule bonne nouvelle dans
tout cela c'est que la croissance
française résiste et elle résiste
justement parce que notre politique de
l'offre commence à donner des résultats
et elle résiste parce que nous avons un
pouvoir d'achat pour les ménages
français en 2019 qui a augmenté de près
de 2 points ce qui fait que la
consommation des ménages français
notamment au deuxième trimestre a
fortement augmenté ce qui est la preuve
que notre politique économique
aujourd'hui est sur la bonne voie mais
c'est la seule bonne nouvelle dans un
environnement international qui est
effectivement négatif en suisse au
niveau de la dette
je rappelle juste que comme vous l'avez
très bien dit mais sur l'importance
générale avant la crise financière
nous étions à 60 % d'endettement public
qu'ensuite nous avons massivement
dépensés pour compenser cette crise
financière et économique
sauf que comme nous n'avons pas dans le
même temps réduit structurellement la
par la dépense publique n'avons pas
ensuite retrouvé des niveaux de dettes
qui sont satisfaisants à cela s'ajoute
un stand de décisions par exemple la
reprise la dette de la sncf c'est quand
même 35 milliards d'euros
sap est évidemment ce niveau
d'endettement public français mais si
nous voulons faire baisser cette dette
publique
les deux seuls leviers efficaces que je
connais c'est la croissance
nous l'avons et ce à la réduction
structurelle la dépense publique devront
commencer à le faire
est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin ma
réponse est oui je pense qu'il faut
poursuivre cette baisse de la dépense
publique dans les années qui viennent et
surtout pas perdre ce fils là parce
qu'on le paye sinon après avec un niveau
d'endettement qui est élevé enfin sur la
comparaison avec l'allemagne merci
d'avoir rappelé qu'en 2007
à la fin du quinquennat de jacques
chirac et dominique de villepin est en
premier ministre des comptes publics
étaient effectivement rétabli 60% de
dette la croissance était là et le
chômage était un niveau extrêmement bas
preuve que le quinquennat avait été
efficace mais si d'allemagne à des
comptes publics qui sont bien tenues
elle a une croissance qui est
inquiétante et donc lorsqu'on est dans
cette situation là je pense que la seule
conclusion en tirer comme nous
l'expliquons à tous les niveaux de
gouvernement allemand c'est qu' il vaut
mieux investir pour éviter la situation
se dégrade davantage sur un impact pour
les allemands mais aussi pour l'ensemble
la zone euro on va donc mettre en oeuvre
la rls ou plutôt le les mesures qui sont
sortis de la fameuse clause de revoyure
un accord entre l'état les bailleurs
sociaux action logement il support de la
caisse des dépôts pour essayer de faire
en sorte que malgré les économies vous
avez réalisé sur les loyers en tous les
cas appel baisse des loyers les
conséquences de tout cela ne soit pas
trop dure
ceci étant dit mme sioniste messieurs
les ministres la caisse des dépôts vient
de sortir son étude sur les perspectives
du logement social que dit cette étude
tirant les conséquences de la clause de
revoyure elle dit que l'endettement des
bailleurs sociaux va passer de 160
milliards à 300 milliards d'ici 20 ans
alors vous me direz la dette et pas
maastricht yens donc c'est moins
embêtant mais enfin tout de même sur
cette base là les bailleurs sociaux
devrait pouvoir produire 100 mille
logements par an ce qui est peu
puisqu'on a parfois produit 120 130
mille logements il y en aura plus que
cent mille et à quelles conditions dit
aqesss
et bien c'est simple il faut expiré que
les taux d'intérêt ne remonte pas trop
et ça ici personne ne peut le dire
il faut également que les regroupements
des bailleurs se passe dans de bonnes
conditions et troisième condition que la
vente hlm atteignent le niveau de 17 18
mille par an c'est à dire le double de
ce qui a été fait dans le passé
alors messieurs les ministres
donnez-vous toutes les chances de
réussir est d'atteindre cet objectif de
300 mille deux cent mille logements
construits par an rétablissons la paix à
l'accession on va vous le redemande et
j'imagine à l'assemblée comme ici mais
c'est une petite dépense mais avec un
effet de levier à mon avis important
pour le secteur du logement social
deuxième question le gouvernement a
décidé alors qu'il avait signé un accord
avec action logement qui a beaucoup fait
quand même pour sortir le gouvernement
de l'ornière dans laquelle il était avec
l'air à l'aise action logement a mis
beaucoup d'argent sur la table
ils ont très mal récompensés puisqu'ils
ont appris je vais pas dire pas la
presse mais presque que vous alliez
ponctionner 500 millions dans les cases
action logement
alors question c'est pour une année où
c'est définitif
parce qu'il semble qu'il y ait
effectivement une inquiétude là dessus
et puis je vais pousser la question quel
est l'avenir du 1% logement messieurs
les ministres parce qu'aujourd'hui
enfin c'est 0,45 me tout le monde se
demande quelle est l'intention du
gouvernement est ce qu'on va finir un
jour ou l'autre par dire allez terminer
on remet ça dans les caisses de l'état
et puis troisième question je fais très
vite monsieur le président les
compensations des exodes tfpb on va
supprimer la taxe d'habitation pour les
communes avec les conséquences que ça va
avoir l récupérons tout le foncier bâti
je vous le redis messieurs les ministres
pour les maires ça veut dire quoi
si vous construisez du logement social
aucune entrée fiscale si vous
construisez du logement intermédiaire
aucune rentrée fiscale puisque les
bailleurs sont exonérés pendant 20 ou 25
ans et plus de taxe d'habitation
donc si vous voulez soutenir le logement
et la construction qui en a bien besoin
il faut supprimer cette perte pour les
communes puisque l'état accorde exode
tfpb mais au bout du compte ce sont les
communes qui les payent
l'année dernière vous nous aviez dit que
les exodes tsb c'était un milliard en
fait il ya semble-t-il 413 millions
d'euros qui vont aux communes trouver
une solution je ne sais pas laquelle on
peut discuter d'un éventuel péréquation
entre communes je ne sais pas mais que
l'état fait ça fasse un accord que les
collectivités fassent un effort mais il
faut trouver une solution à ce problème
allez roger karoutchi puis sylvie
vermeillet ben tiens monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je vais
être rapide et très synthétique d'abord
je prends l'exemple de l'audiovisuel
puisque je suis à porter à la matière on
apprend avant même d'avoir le texte de
loi sur la réforme de l'audiovisuel que
l'action première c'est de baisser dans
l'hérault la redevance
en parallèle bien sûr on va ouvrir la
publicité plus largement et dans le
service public et dans le secteur privé
est ce que c'est une vraie politique est
ce que j'avais entendu de la part du
président la république mais aussi de la
part du gouvernement une volonté de
réforme y compris de réforme du
financement des deux visuels
visiblement on ne veut pas le faire on
va se contenter totalement à la marge
d'enlever la 1 euro de mettre là une
coupure de pub supplémentaire sur les
films franchement c'est pas du
financement à terme de l'audiovisuel et
ça m'amène non pas à une autre question
mais à une extension on entend dire que
sur certaines dépenses sociales le
gouvernement respecte l'inflation va au
delà sur d'autres un peu moins que
l'inflation sur certaines allocations
mais vous avez fait un effort messieurs
les ministres sur les niches fiscales en
essayant de rationaliser de voir ce qui
pourrait être supprimée ce qui devait
être maintenue ce qui devait être
renforcée pourquoi est ce que nous
n'avons toujours pas en la matière une
mise à plat de l'ensemble des
allocations et des dépenses sociales
pour regarder ce qui est efficient
regardez ce qui est efficace
regardez ce qu'il est - et peut-être
avoir une remise en cause plus globale
que le simple fait de faire en sorte que
ce soit fixée ou pas sur l'inflation
vous avez évoqué monsieur d'ail et la
question du logement alors on pourrait
disserter à l'envi
sur les hypothèses notamment l'hypothèse
de la caisse que nous regardons avec
avec avec sérieux mais dont les
hypothèses se fonde sur le fait qu'un
retournement éléments de croissance
économique si je m'en souviens bien des
années qu'ils sont pas les mêmes sur
lequel on a calculé le rls et y compris
la clause de revoyure qui a été accepté
d'ailleurs par les partenaires du
logement et sur la question des taux
d'intérêt pour toujours se poser la
question de savoir si taux d'intérêt
vont continuer à être bas le fait est
que manifestement toutes les banques
centrales commencent à évoquer
qu'effectivement les hypothèses sur
lesquelles on travaille 2020 ne sont pas
remises en cause
j'ajouterai ce fait vous avez été élu
maire comme moi même avant moi monsieur
le sénateur que la veille des élections
municipales notamment l'année 2019
il est assez rare qu'une production
absolue permis de construire pour genève
selon tous les voisins à tout moment
mais nous entendons la question qui se
pose sur la construction de logements
ont posé la question de ce que nous
faisons est aux rayures et là des
avantages et des inconvénients mais
n'oublions pas ce qu'a fait notamment
misé l'économie avec la caisse même s'il
y avait des épargnants il a revu les
taux d'intérêt pour l'épargné des
français c'est une action extrêmement
forte en faveur du logement je rappelle
que nous baissons c'est le cas du projet
est financé à tva pour la cour de la
construction de logements sociaux et
nous remettons un certain nombre de
clauses d'assouplissement pour la vente
même si vous avez tout à fait raison la
question de la vente du montant de vente
fait partie des incertitudes des années
qui viennent on est tous d'accord pour
dire que ça fait partie aussi de la
façon nouvelle dont on doit imaginer la
construction du logement par contre je
vous suis peu sur l'action action
logement
je rappelle qu'il ya quatre milliards de
trésorerie à l'action logement et je
rappelle que vous dites ça reviendra
dans l'état est ce que c'est un
prélèvement obligatoire par ailleurs
action logement récupère ou appeler le 1
% nous avons 35 sa palette en ligue à
thouars et récupère de l'argent on a
constaté malheureusement on le regrette
et et avec une liste à du logement
il ya une sauce exécution de
l'engagement d'action logement sans
doute est ce compliqué il ya plusieurs
raisons pour cela d'ailleurs l'état
regarde ça au conseil d'administration
de l'application des engagements avec
son logement notamment sur ce qu'il
avait prévu de faire on leur a demandé
c'est le cas des 500 millions que vous
évoquez un monsieur monsieur le sénateur
sur les appels d'être au rendez vous
mais il y a quatre milliards d'euros de
trésorerie nette à prélèvements
obligatoires sur les entreprises alors
que on aura sans doute l'occasion de
reparler de ces questions de logement
donc vous êtes spécialiste enfin
monsieur karoutchi puisque monsieur
rénald la réponse a été faite par
monsieur par monsieur de merde moi je
partage pas votre opinion d'ailleurs
dans votre intervention vous mélangez
l'audiovisuel et le visuel public
bon c'est pas pareil vous le savez mais
personne puisque ça fait longtemps le
trait sur ces questions la baisse d'un
euro de la redevance télé elle est
légitime dans la mesure où un euro c'est
25 millions c'est une taxe affectée à
partir du moment où par ailleurs vous
demandez des économies à l'audiovisuel
public sur la réforme que porte ministre
la culture et de l'audiovisuel qui est
conforme à l'engagement présidentiel du
président de la république vous avais tu
es à peu près une centaine de millions
d'euros qui sont aux portes et comme
l'économie dans le plf sur l'audiovisuel
public soit on considérait qu'il fallait
garder un montant important de redevance
télé est le produit de cette redevance
télé rentrée sous plafond et re été
reversée à l'état donc on accepter
l'idée que la taxe affectée qui était
fait pour l'audiovisuel public
vas y avait un monde qu'elle est trop
d'argent pardon de le dire ainsi vous le
remettez à l'état seront partez du
principe qu'il fallait en effet de
manière peut-être symbolique rentrer
prendre quelque chose qui n'a pas été
fait depuis très très nombreuses années
une décrue d'une redevance dont le
milieu culture lui-même mais le
président de la république l'a déjà
évoqué évidemment que les questions de
fiscalité audiovisuel sera au rendez
vous alors on a un problème pratique sur
quoi on à dos la redevance télé puisque
jusqu'à présent elle est adossée à taxe
d'habitation n'a trouvé une solution
pour les années qui viennent sera
adossée à l'impôt sur le revenu
notamment à la déclaration de revenus et
el al à la feuille d'impôts qu'on
enverra pour le labour survenu non plus
à adosser à la th
qu'est-ce qui a passionné prochaine 80%
de français n'auront plus de taxe
d'habitation en a payé et après le
ministre de la culture a évoqué lui-même
qu'il réfléchissait avec nous mais en
lui en premier à quelle est la bonne
fiscalité de demain pour la réforme de
visuels vous mélangez un autre sujet si
je puis me permettre notamment la
question de la publicité et dans la loi
audiovisuel public
il ya notamment la question deux pour le
privé est-ce qu'on accepte notamment
l'ouverture de la publicité non pas
simplement en page de publicité
notamment la publicité géolocalisée par
exemple qui pose d'autres problèmes
notamment de
presse quotidienne régionale et
d'encarts de la publicité
donc pour répondre à la question de
votre de votre intervention
ça fait pas une politique de baisser 1
euros la redevance télé chacun le
comprend mais le plf il n'est pas là
pour faire la réforme du public puisque
les noix spécifique qui arrive dans le
suis sûr vous aurez l'occasion d'en
reparler
et c'est une taxe affectée et donc on
met le montant d'argent dont on a besoin
et on prend pas plus d'argent aux
français qu'on en a besoin
olivier du soft commis plusieurs faits
merci monsieur le président de quelques
questions effectivement monsieur gainey
de monsieur del crown / ap un mois ci de
monsieur vallier sur les questions de
fiscalité locale sur la question du
calendrier d'abord calendrier de
suppression de la taxe d'habitation donc
née 80% ménages qui en bénéficient
aujourd'hui paieront pour la dernière
fois dans les semaines qui viennent un
tiers taxe d'habitation et l'année
prochaine ils ne paieront plus rien ce
qui est un pic pour l'état de faire
monter les recettes de compensation en
les 20% de ménages continuant à
contribuer à la taxe d'habitation ne
nous en paierons que les deux tiers puis
un tiers en 2001 2 et ne paieront plus
rien en 2023
là où il ya un calendrier tout le temps
qu'ils jouent entre 22 et 23
c'est parce que les ménages vous arrête
de payer en 22 mais l'état doit assurer
la compensation aux collectivités sa
montée en charge jusqu'à 23 et il n'y a
aucun risque que l'état puisse reverser
moins que ce qu'ils prélèvent aux
communes
d'abord parce que ça passe par le compte
d' avance et et vous le verriez manière
assez directe et c'est peut-être là une
belle garantie et ensuite parce que
généralement le tout bien sûr une
période longue l'évolution des valeurs
locatives des communes est assez
homogène sur l'ensemble des valeurs
locatives quelle que soit la situation
la commune le seul risque que l'on a
décelé cécile les valeurs locatives des
communes sous compenser augmenté
beaucoup plus vite que les valeurs
locatives des communes surcompensé il y
aura un risque pour l'état mais pas un
risque pour les communes 70 ans risque
de coût pour l'état que l' inverse par
ailleurs la clause de revoyure vous
permettra de le mesurer et de le
vérifier
la deuxième chose sur le calendrier vous
avez évoqué les valeurs locatives
nous avons fait le choix de ne pas
lancer immédiatement le chantier de la
révision générale des valeurs locatives
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
techniquement c'est un chantier qui est
très conséquent puisque de 2014 2017
c'était la révision des valeurs
locatives professionnels
pour trois millions cinq cent mille bien
là nous parlons de 48 millions de biens
avec des écarts qui sont conséquents
donc techniquement c'est un chantier
extrêmement lourd et nous considérons
que la priorité doit être de solidifier
la réforme de la fiscalité locale pour
une application intégrale en termes de
recettes pour les communes dans les
collectivités en 2021 il ya une deuxième
raison qui est beaucoup plus politique
et qui a été que nous avons entendu en
tout cas moz raison tendu qui doit
donner une bonne raison
aso légère hopper c'est la petite
confusion que certains semblaient
vouloir faire naître entre la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation et
une révision générale qui était présenté
comme le moyen de financer la
suppression de la th
et vous avez certainement vu ou lu ses
articles ses discours expliquant que
finalement ça allait faire exploser la
taxe foncière ce qu'il faut par ailleurs
puisque on sait qu'une révision générale
c'est plutôt autour de 4% mais ce n'est
pas le produit de la th
cela a été dit dans des discours de
rentrée d'un parti que je ne citerai pas
mais qui est plutôt à l'extrême droite
de l'échiquier politique
ça a été dit y compris par des députés
je pense à monsieur robert à l'assemblée
nationale qui a utilisé cet argument
nous ne voulons pas que cette confusion
naissent dans l'esprit des contribuables
d'où ce report j'entends votre crainte
sur la durée ça fait quarante neuf ans
qu'on attend la révision je pense très
sincèrement qu'on peut en attendre deux
ou trois de plus sur la question de
l'indexation dollars par don de la
revalorisation forfaitaire des valeurs
locatives par la loi de finances nous
proposons effectivement dans le plf qui
vous est soumis que les valeurs
locatives de la taxe d'habitation pour
les résidences principales et uniquement
pour les résidences principales ne soit
pas revalorisé faut faire
forfaitairement en 2020 mais que ne soit
pris en compte que l'évolution physique
de ses bases nous aurons une
revalorisation forfaitaire pour la taxe
foncière pour la taxe d'habitation sur
les résidences secondaires
mais le fait d'être sur l'année de
calcul l'année de référence nous amène à
faire cette proposition là sur les
autres questions que vous avez
évoquée a été évoquée la question de
l'impact de la modification du panier de
recettes fiscales des collectivités sur
le calcul du potentiel fiscal qui
détermine notamment les dotations de
péréquation c'est un élément que l'on a
en tête c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous vous présentons cette
réforme maintenant
avec une application en 2021 nous aurons
un nom pour voir si les modalités de
calcul du potentiel fiscal peuvent être
améliorés parce que c'est une demande
assez récurrente et ainsi neutraliser
l'effet que vous craignez tout en
mettant plus de justice si nous
n'arrivions pas parce qu'on sait que le
chantier d'ampleur quand il s'agit de
réviser le mode de calcul du potentiel
fiscal
si nous n'arrivions pas à le faire nous
pourrons dans le plf pour 2021 adopté
une disposition de neutralisation pour
que nous ne connaissions pas en 2022
première année de versements de dotation
tenant compte d'un potentiel fiscal avec
le nouveau panier de recettes connaître
le même phénomène que nous avons connue
en 2018 avec une évolution du potentiel
fiscal il ya des changements de
périmètres intercommunaux et pas à une
évolution économique du territoire mais
en tout cas c'est bien entendu sur les
simulations j'ai l'occasion je ne sais
pas si c'est arrivé jusqu à vous
monsieur le président mais nous avons
signé avec gérald darmanin
il y a deux jours ou trois jours un
courrier vous précisons que l'ensemble
des directions départementale des
finances publiques avait instruction
d'une autre barre de donner les
simulations aux élus qui le souhaitent
monsieur le président du sénat
souhaitait avoir accès à des simulations
de manière plus globale et le premier
ministre se charge de lui transmettre
ces simulations il m'indiquait lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
qu'il avait signé le courrier dans les
dernières heures donc ça devrait lui
arriver mais toutes les simulations
seront données j'ai entendu le ministre
le maire parlait de regard lucide sur ce
projet de loi de finances je partage et
je dirais que en creux peut-être c'est
un changement d'approché pour ne pas
dire de ton par rapport à l'an passé où
on avait entendu beaucoup
la musique du pouvoir du budget du
pouvoir d'achat malheureusement deux
mois après les événements se sont faits
la situation s'est gravement détériorée
deuxième élément sur le verdissement du
budget du document en fait vous avez
raison c'est une bonne base de départ
parce que quand on regarde grandes
étapes de 2017 à 2019
vous faites état notamment de cinq temps
forts le 1er janvier 2017 se faire de ma
part c'était sous le gouvernement du
quinquennat précédent et les quatre
autres temps forts en fait y'a rien
puisque c'est uniquement des sommets ou
des organes que vous mettez en place
je rappelle que vous êtes ici au
parlement et que donc s'adresse plutôt à
constate de l'inaction ce qui nous
invite collectivement être plus
attentifs trois courtes questions sur
les crédits alloués aux énergies
renouvelables et à l'ademe le les
crédits baissent d'un milliard en 2020
donc comment expliquer ce recul sur le
soutien aux énergies renouvelables
quel sera le montant du fonds chaleur
pour l'ademe sur les deux casses
transition énergétique aide à
l'acquisition des véhicules propres
là encore le cas ce transition
énergétique baisse de 1 milliard quelles
sont les explications et enfin l'article
33 du projet de finances prévoit la
suppression à compter du 1er janvier
ducasse dead à l'acquisition des
véhicules propres pour le passer au
budget général
quelle en est la motivation deux
questions une concernant la fraude
donc on voit que ce projet de loi
prévoit plusieurs mesures pour renforcer
les pouvoirs des agents du fisc et de la
douane
la question porte à la fois sur les
décisions passées et sur les
propositions de ce plf attend un premier
retour notamment en matière de contrôle
à la suite de l'adoption de la loi
fraude
peut-on estimer l'impact budgétaire des
mesures de lutte contre la faute prévu
duster ce plf et notamment en matière de
tva comme la collecte par les
plateformes internet
il n'y a pas de baisse des crédits de
l'état sur le soutien aux énergies
renouvelables
mais comme l'électricité est plus cher
quand on rachète d'électricité puisque
ces principes notamment parce d'énergies
renouvelables évidemment l'état fait des
opérations financières si j'ose dire de
constatation ce qu'on appelle des
économies constatations c'est à dire
deux ans de suite que cela ait constaté
et d'ailleurs il ya même si on était
dans le dévoilement des discussions
budgétaires que j'ai eu avec monsieur de
régis pièce madame bornes c'est déjà le
cas avec monsieur hulot on regarde quel
l'économie constatations et les les
dépenses budgétaires supplémentaires
faites pour le mystère de notre et
sociologiques sont largement supérieures
aux économies constatations des prix
fixés par la crue qui ne sont que des
prévisions et qu'on revoit donc il n'y a
pas en tout cas c'était votre question
et je la prends comme tel mais ne
faisons pas croire qu'il y à des baisses
de crédits sur les énergies
renouvelables bien au contraire
on aura l'occasion sans doute d'en
reparler de nouveau sur allart
budgétisation elle est très importante
pour la simplification
elle est aussi très importante pour ce
qui est d'un sujet qui va sans doute
passionnés dans les années qui viennent
et singulièrement dans le budget de
l'année prochaine sont les empreintes
vert que nous faisons les oaa était
verte que nous faisons aujourd'hui on
fait à peu près 5 milliard il ya un
stock de 19 milliards de watts et verte
c'est-à-dire des emprunts sur les
marchés financiers qui relève de la
finance verte avec des gens qui nous
prêtent à des prix défiant toute
concurrence simplement ils veulent qu'on
finance et des agissements des dépenses
verte et nous avons le plus grand mal
aujourd'hui à trouver d'autres dépenses
que celles que nous avons déjà affectées
et quand on leur dit mais regardez il ya
beaucoup de dépenses énergétiques ils
disent oui mais vous avez déjà une
recette dans le cas ce qui affecte et
qui permet de dépenser donc pour un
financier on lui fait pas payer deux
fois
sachant qu'il a déjà une recette qui est
affecté donc l'un des problèmes mais
c'est une question d'habitation
budgétaire et on aura l'occasion des
suites avec mu l'économie les ministres
en charge et sans doute vos commissions
si on veut augmenter le nombre doigté
verte parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent
sur les marchés financiers pour que la
france puisse emprunter
selon un green endettement jeu pas comme
on pourrait l'appeler en tout cas des
des prêts de gens qui nous prêtent que
pour des dépenses verte il faut
absolument qu'on fasse d'une part le
budget
vers que nous allons préparer en 2021
puisque nous avons je crois un excellent
rapport de l'inspection générale des
finances et d'inspection du ministère de
transition écologique mais aussi en
peut-être budgétisant une partie des cas
ce qui nous permettent d'augmenter le
montant de la finance verte pour notre
budget en tout cas sans le social ne
faisons pas ça nous allons continuer
effectivement avoir des emprunts
largement éloignés de la finance verte
voulue par la france dans le cadre
notamment de ces accords est de ces
annonces internationale sur les
contrôles pour répondre merci pour votre
soutien
le sénateur sur le pré des ressources
est avant tout une réussite de
l'administration fiscale qui est sous
mon autorité
ce qui est sûr c'est que la lutte contre
la fraude fiscale en 2019 sera
particulièrement performante
nous n'avons pas encore les chiffres
définitifs des contentieux fiscaux qu'on
aura réglé
d'ailleurs ce intermédiaire devant la
commission que google a réglé le montant
de son impôt donc elle a versé de
l'argent qu'elle était évoqué sa
comprennent et 2019 jeudi pour monsieur
rénale qui avait danger avant 2019 et
2020 d'autres contentieux ont été rendus
publics donc je ne trahis pas le secret
fiscal dans les dix ans devant votre
commission publiquement c'est le cas de
l'oréal
c'est le cas des autres gaffard qui ont
révoqué
amazon et apple qui avait cité eux mêmes
les règlements contentieux que j'ai pu
mettre à profit de l'administration
fiscale en rappelant d'ailleurs que dans
la sphère google nous perdions au
tribunal et nous perdions notre évident
à une sortie de paris et j'avais fait
appel nous avons perdu en cour d'appel
nous étions dans le conseil dans le
conseil d'état ça plus le fait que nous
réglons à sa nombre de contentieux qui
sera pourtant je rame se présentent des
commissions pourraient à l'envi venir
voir les choses aussi de souhaiter
personnellement mais je ne peux évoquer
ici font qu'en 2019 sans doute ce sera
l'année la plus importante de
recouvrement du conteux contentieux
fraude fiscale que nous aurons constaté
jeudi autant plus que cette année le
gouvernement a essayé de mettre en place
ce que cela avait demandé déjà mais que
personne n'avait osé faire puisqu'il ya
une différence fondamentale dans les
chiffres
ne parlons pas des contentieux notifié
désormais mais le ballon bien de
l'argent qui rentre dans les caisses ce
qui est assez différent notification
évidemment est assez différente de ce
qu'on retient à la fin on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler pour le verrou
de bercy par exemple il est trop tôt
pour en tirer des conclusions
mais je salue bien volontiers l'aide du
sénat et singulièrement soit transaction
pénale on a eu ces discussions qui nous
a permis de régler notamment la sphère
la sphère google c'est un point très
important
je le dis pour le prg le sénateur harb
haut sur le verrou des rssi on a
augmenté de 85% le dossier transmis au
parquet suit notamment la circulaire que
j'ai cosigné avec madame la ministre de
la justice garde garde des sceaux par
rapport au semestre précédent
il faut désormais que 100 de notre
commission c'est ce que me permettre
cette invitation
ça intéresse peut-être dans quelques
mois à soir le nombre d' enquêtes qui
ont été effectivement ouvertes par le
pouvoir judiciaire par l'autorité
judiciaire et je suis d'ailleurs heureux
de vous dire que la police fiscale que
vous avez contribué à créer a déjà été
saisi de nombreux dossiers sont confiés
par les magistrats sur doute gage de la
sincérité et du sérieux des officiers
puisqu'au judiciaire voilà pour cette
audition que vous avez pu suivre sur
l'antenne de public sénat merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi c'est la fin de cette
émission pouvez voir ou revoir toutes
nos émissions sur publicsenat.fr
très bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
non
monde